Welcome to the Lightsaber Helpdesk.
Ah, hello, yes, I'm having trouble with my lightsaber.
Can I have your account number, please?
My account?
Where do I find that?
It's the five-digit serial number on the handle.
Ah, yes, I see.
It's 00001.
How can I help you today, Mr. Wader?
It's Vader!
Lord Darth Vader!
Okay, Mr. Waiter, whatever.
How can I help you?
It's Vade... it doesn't matter.
Look, my lightsaber won't make the "Voom!" sound when it comes on.
Have you tried changing the batteries?
I have replaced them.
I'd like to speak to your supervisor.
Well, have you pushed the reset button on the bottom of the handle?
Ah, yes, I know about this.
Could you just tell me how to do it again?
Yep, try turning it 30 degrees, press reset and tap the handle at the same time.
Everybody knows that.
Ah, 30 degrees and, press and, hang on.
I'm sorry, oops.
Everything okay there?
Oh, it's all working fine.
Thank you.
Thank you for calling the Lightsaber Helpdesk.